die leiche von andrea kam aus der weser
nahe dem niedersächsischen balve
geborgen nacht ihre hände sind auf den
rücken gefesselt an ihren füßen wurde
eine beton gebunden wird unseren vater
hat viele auseinandersetzungen so keine
gut begründet wird er war ihr zuhälter
aber auch ihr freund das heißt dass dies
eine geplante ein geplanter mord oder
man muss leider fast auch sagen in
richtung war das echt so ist seine
eigene schwester flächen bluetooth hals
gehalten würde ich sowieso ermordet
wurde sie wurde mit einem betonklotz in
der weser versenkt sie waren nackt und
die knoten waren extrem kompliziert wir
reden über über komplizierte bondage
knoten
du wirst mir aufgewachsen so das ist das
einzige was gott geschenkt hat man hat
ein seltsames eine seltsame mischung aus
beziehungstat aber auch klaren bezügen
zur illegalen prostitution tablett aus
diesem zuhälter wie ist ein brutaler
zurück das hab ich gehört so dass auf
eine hölle schmoren das wünsche ich nur
auf jeden fall hier besteht kaum ein
zweifel dass das nicht wahr was impulsiv
aus einem streit heraus spontan passiert
ist sondern dass dies eine geplante ein
geplanter mord oder man muss leider fast
aufsagen hinrichtung warten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie gibt es musik zu hören
sie hätte gerne gefeiert mal so eine
kleine party maus
sie fand die sonne sehr gut ihr
lieblingsessen spaghetti
sie liebte es klamotten anzuziehen sich
ständig umzuziehen auf jeden fall an
sich zu schminken
sie hat auch sehr viel für uns brüder
auch getan sie hat geschenke gemacht war
von star lebensinhalt freundin ich darf
was andere ja so als finde auf dem
reagiert mit der kleinen schwester zug
fahren oder mit ihr zu hause einen film
schauen
für den 21 jährigen gregor sind diese
fotos voller erinnerungen und es sind
die letzten aufnahmen mit seiner
schwester andrea kurz vor ihrem tod
sie war seine spielgefährtin seine
familie
die geschwister waren früh auf sich
alleine gestellt die mutter verließ sie
und ging zurück nach polen
der vater war oft überfordert verstarb
2018 an ludwigs gemeinsam erlebten
andrea und gregor mit ihren zwei brüdern
höhen und tiefen
[Musik]
wir hatten mit unserem vater hat viele
auseinandersetzungen also keine gute
kindheit gehabt so ich hab mal so keine
kindheit gehabt so ein paar gute momente
gab es
aber mein vater hat sich trotzdem
gekümmert wird versucht so meine
schwester ist oft in heimen gekommen so
weil sie als im aus der reihe getanzt
hat so sie hat sich nicht angepasst gar
nicht so ja irgendein mensch das
tragische leben von andrea k
sie soll drogen genommen und als
prostituierte gearbeitet haben
mit 16 wird sie das erste mal schwanger
es ist ein mädchen
der vater verlässt die junge familie ein
jahr später wird ihr sohn geboren beide
kinder wachsen bei einer pflegefamilie
auf andrea darf sie lediglich besuchen
das wollte die 19-jährige dieses jahr
endlich ändern
sie plante ihre kinder zurückzuholen das
erzählte sie auch ihren bruder gregor
dazu kontakt zu meiner schwester war
mitte märz vergebens weiterungen dass
sie halt ihre kinder wieder zurück haben
möchte so nicht hat sie gefragt habe ob
alles in ordnung ist
sie war sehr angespannt ist kann ich
viel mehr dazu sagen
so waren traf auf werden nicht glücklich
so in diesem zeitpunkt zu gestalten
so geschehen dass sie glücklich ist aber
ich glaube nicht ich glaube ich hatte
selbst eine komische anspannung dabei
am 28 april 2020 wird die leiche von
andrea k aus der weser nahe dem
niedersächsischen balke geborgen
sie ist nackt ihre hände sind auf dem
rücken gefesselt an ihren füßen wurde
eine betonplatte gebunden
die obduktion ergab dass die zweifache
mutter noch lebte als ihr unter wasser
gezogen wurde
sie ertrank andrea wurde opfer eines
grausamen verbrechens
ich habe das verfahren am 28 april
es war glaube ich sagen frühe morgen ab
12 uhr so da kann herr mertens mit einer
frau zum kollegen und er hat mir ja
genau ich über braucht so dass meine
schwester verstorben ist so und das war
halt eine tragische sache für mich so
ich bin halt vom polizeirevier
zusammengebrochen so ein kollege hat
mich halt den arm genommen weil das
recht hat seine eigene schwester dann
fleisch und blut zu erhalten
möglicherweise ermordet wurde sodass
hart für einen familienangehörigen wo du
denkst du wirst mir aufgewachsen so das
ist das einzige was gott hier geschenkt
so die polizei sucht mit hochdruck nach
dem mörder von andrea es gibt sogar eine
belohnung in höhe von 5000 euro für
hinweise die zum täter führen
die staatsanwaltschaft verden zu den
ermittlungen also kann ich sagen dass
die ermittlungen zu diesem grausamen
verbrechen nach wie vor andauern
weiterhin befinden sich vier personen
drei männer und eine frau in
untersuchungshaft gegen eine beteiligung
an einem mord zum nachteil von andrea k
zur last gelegt
der fall für die ermittler ins
rotlicht-milieu der haupttäter soll der
40 jährige stefan k sein
ein mutmaßlicher zuhälter aus nienburg
er lebt knapp 20 autominuten vom tatort
entfernt in diesem einfamilienhaus
ebenfalls verdächtigt ist auch diego de
der ex-freund von andrea ich habe auch
gehört dass er wie die liebe vorgespielt
hat so das finde ich auch nicht gut oder
auch erzählt dass diese prostitution
gezwungen hat so das war hat schon
schöningen angefangen so ich wusste
nichts davon ich kam aus flensburg
abgeordnete wie mein vater würde er
verstorben ist entschuldigen
da bin ich abgehauen ich komme wieder
weil ich halt sachen gehört habe aber
ich muss ja die ganzen informationen
halt auf den grund gehen
dann hab ich halt gehört für ein paar
leuten sie und dann bin ich ausgerastet
ich mal richtig ausgerastet so ich habe
ihm die nachricht geschickt so was soll
man halt auch eine gebühr bild bin ich
ehrlich ich habe mir als gewirbelt für
den fall analytiker markt t hofmann ist
der mord an der andrea k ein fall mit
mehreren tätern motiven
sie war die ex freundin einer der
mutmaßlichen täter oder jetzt in
untersuchungshaft sitzenden aber
gleichzeitig er war ihr zuhälter aber
auch ihr freund das heißt man hat
sozusagen ein oder ex frontmann hat ein
seltsames eine seltsame mischung aus
beziehungstat aber auch klaren bezügen
zur illegalen prostitution und gerade
wenn es mehrere täter gibt kann sich das
durchaus mission aber der hass der in
diesem verbrechen doch deutlich wird
deutet darauf hin dass es auch eine
persönliche verbindung gibt dass es auch
eine beziehungstat ist eine der beweise
oder indizien auf die sich die
staatsanwaltschaft ja verlässt ist ja
die kommunikation zwischen diesen
tatverdächtigen diese diese planung der
austausch darüber
das heißt hier besteht kaum ein zweifel
dass das nicht wahr was impulsiv aus
einem streit heraus spontan passiert ist
sondern dass dies eine geplante ein
geplanter mord oder man muss leider fast
auch sagen hinrichtungen war
ich habe gehört dass diesem zuhälter wie
ist ein brutaler zu hause das hab ich
gehört so dass er in der hölle schmoren
das wünsche ich mir auf jeden fall
ja aber ich bin damals gab es außerdem
auf so einer auseinandersetzung
also das bin ich fest geschlossen wird
fahrt ins niedersächsische schöningen
hier wohnte andrea im dritten stock
eines mehrfamilienhauses
nachbarn erzählen dass es in der wohnung
oft sehr laut war letztes jahr kurz vor
weihnachten wurde hier sogar
eingebrochen
andrea brutal überfallen seit dem tod
seiner schwester war gregor nicht mehr
in der wohnung
[Musik]
ich finde es komisch dass ist machen wir
jetzt an sparen
zu tun wir
wie finden sie denn denken haben sie
das ist auch in gott
also wir von ihnen fehlt ist die worte
ich kann uns sofort nichts mehr sagen
es ist immer noch so wie meine schwester
verlassen also die staatsanwaltschaft
meinte der kanadier bis nicks
freigegeben wurde
[Musik]
alles unter
gregor muss zum zweiten mal abschied
nehmen von einem geliebten
familienmitglied nach seinem vater ist
es nun seine kleine schwester
sie hat für die geschenke gemacht so für
uns so und das hat uns auch zum lachen
gebracht sie hatten das klamotten
gekauft weil sie sagst du sie als
hübsche brüder so sie holten das
bisschen so auf könnten somit klamotten
in jakub janda von hier
deswegen hab ich dir das auch also ich
gebe ja nicht weg gebe ich nicht die
wurststückchen reifer in dem sinne dass
du halt lernst im leben so auch diese
option zu wählen so wenn du alt
familienangehörige hast und ich darum zu
kümmern dass sie an vernünftigen absolut
programm gehabt das hat es schon früher
alles mitbekommen so dass menschen gehen
ja egal wie schwer es ist so sie ist
trotzdem beide auch wenn sie jetzt vor
dass der text jetzt immer noch
[Musik]
wirklich grundstücke sind bei 12
durchsuchen vorläufig sichergestellt
worden
hengsbach schön kurz das zimmer deine
freiheit
[Musik]